that Islam basically gave rise to
feudalism in the dark age. And lo and
behold, these Arabs just come out of
nowhere, out of Arabia, out of the
deserts and start intentionally
attacking and desecrating everything.
It's flaring out because the West itself
is allowing this, provoking this, being
stupid, being passive. Yeah. They took
her and they basically put her on the
altar of Haga Sophia and gang raped her
intentionally with a large crucifix
underneath her head by way of mocking,
of course. And yes, the Turks were
renowned for being pedophiles, little
boys. It's my deepest dive into the
Crusades.
>> Hi, this is Justin Kurrion, your host
here at Reclaiming Christianom. Today we
have a fantastic interview with Raymond
Ibraham, the author of Sword and
Scimitar, and numerous other
bestsellers. But we're going to discuss
Sword and Scitar today where Raymond
discusses eight battles between Islam
and Christianity over a period of a
thousand years and what occurred in
these battles. I can tell you from
reading the book, it is a page turner. I
couldn't put it down and I learned an
awful lot. So, make sure to stay tuned
for the interview and don't forget to
like and subscribe to our channel,
Reclaiming Christianom. Just take a
moment and like and subscribe right now.
We have great content every week, so we
want to make sure to bring it to you.
Okay, get ready. Fasten your seat belts
and let's meet Raymond. Raymond, how you
doing?
>> I'm good, Justin. Thanks. Good to be
with you.
>> Raymond, I have a question. I I noticed
you organized this book very
specifically. It's it's over eight
battles um over a thousand years or we
could even say, you know, the the fight
between Christian Christianity and Islam
over 1,400 years. So, it's it's a very
specific way this book was organized. Uh
just for everyone to know out there, it
covers eight battles, four that the
Muslims won and four that the Christians
won. And I was curious, why did you
choose this format? Was there some
particular reason?
>> No, it was actually pretty organic for
me. Um, the book was meant to be a lot
longer and uh it was meant to cover more
battles, but as I was writing them, each
chapter tended to get longer and longer
because I didn't want just to focus on
the military aspects of the battle. I
wanted to, as anyone who's read Sword
and Scitar knows, it's mostly not about
the battles. It's about the context,
what led up to it, before it, and the
aftermaths, what happened. So each
chapter got really long and um and then
I had to just settle on eight um what I
really thought were the most decisive,
pivotal or iconic. Um and the fact that
it came out four versus four, that's
actually a happy coincidence. Glad it
came out that way. Um it could obviously
if I threw the net further and added
more and more battles, it may have
changed that that equation. But so
that's it was basically organic the way
I approached it. I had been writing
about my thesis, my master's thesis
going way back around late 1999 or so
was actually one of these battles, the
battle of Yarmmuk. So I've always had an
interest in the military history of
Christendom and Islam and my chapter one
was the battle of Yarmmuk because it is
that important even though it's a much
different um than my thesis but yeah so
it just it it just happened naturally.
It was nothing really pre-planned.
>> Okay. Um, I noticed you talked about,
which I think a lot of the listeners
want to hear about in the beginning just
talked about the rise of Islam from the
very beginning with with Muhammad. And
what what I found interesting is his
first, I believe you said his 10 years
in Mecca. He really was not doing too
good getting those recruits. I mean, I
think you said he had about a hundred
after 10 years. So, you know, he wasn't
too getting too popular. And it was only
after he got the boot and headed over to
Medina that suddenly things seemed to
take off. So 10 years only 100 recruits
obviously this this gimmick is not
working. What happened over in Medina
that you exploded and and suddenly the
franchise took off.
>> Well, for whatever reason when you went
to it was it was originally called
Yathre. This was sort of some oasis
town. Now it's called Medina, meaning
the city of light which uh it had a lot
of Arab pagans. had a lot of Jews as
well. And for whatever reason, he was
sort of accepted as this sort of
mediator um so like a wise person who
can help um you know diplomatically
um uh get the tribes to get along with
each other and before long you just find
that he's he rises to the top and he's
essentially a warlord or a chieftain and
all these raids are being orchestrated
in the in his name in the name of Islam.
They're essentially jihads or
in Arabic um on on various caravans and
other tribes and um originally there was
something called the constitution of
Medina which even allowed the followers
of Muhammad and the non-Muslims and the
Jews to actually all work together in
unison. Um but then eventually it just
started as he got stronger and more
powerful and more people joined him. Um
then that's when basically uh we get the
Islam we know today and in fact this is
paralleled by the the the developments
or as they say the revelations of the
Quranic verses that came to Muhammad. So
the earlier ones, Mecca, when he was
weak and outnumbered, they're they tend
to be on the passive uh tolerant um you
know, open-minded kind of thing. Whereas
the Medina ones when he went there and
as he got stronger and stronger, they
become a lot more militant and go
Muslims to go on the offensive. So that
the very last or one of the absolute
lastest latest suras uh surah Toba which
is given the number nine is the one that
is by far the most militant and it has
one verse uh 95 known as a sword verse
which abregates like 120 of the more
peaceful sounding moderate Meccan verses
right
>> um so yeah it's it was a real
development Muslims acknowledge it and
it's even evident in the way the Quran
developed
>> you know you you term we we all use this
term the west now but I I I read in your
book when you use it you you explain
that the west is really the remnant of
Christianom from a much much larger uh
empire and I think a lot of people today
don't realize that so I I think you
pointed out to the point that 66%
of Christianom has been lost and what we
call now is the west is is just a
remnant of a larger empire because if
you talk to people now on the street
they just think of Europe. A lot of
people don't know Christianity was huge
in the east.
>> Yeah. Um like you said when you mention
history and Christianity everyone just
thinks of Europe, the Middle Ages. Um,
they don't realize that the older,
larger, more populous, more
theologically sophisticated region of
Christendom is what is today known as
the Muslim world, which is all of North
Africa from Morocco all the way
eastward, including Algeria, Tunisia,
Libya, and of course, Egypt and the
Middle East, Syria, Lebanon, Israel. It
was it was actually part of the
Christian world at the time. The PA
territories, Jordan, Iraq, and of course
Turkey, you know, which is was Asia
Minor, Anatolia,
that was the heart of Christianity at
the time in the 7th century. You had
five major centers known as seas. Only
one is only one still stood and still
stands and was in Europe, which is Rome.
The other four were in the east.
Alexandria, Constantinople, later uh
Jerusalem and Antioch. And all those
four were eventually conquered and
swallowed up by Islam. Countries like
Egypt were by far much more Christian
populationwise.
Um even as far as activity than most of
Europe in the 7th century. So many of
our, you know, the church fathers
oftentimes they're they have Greek names
and people assume they're Greek because
of Hellenism because the whole Middle
East before Islam were was mostly Greek
speaking peoples. Um but the majority of
them were actually either from Egypt or
Syria. Okay. Um so yes, the idea is
people have completely forgotten and
have lost sight of the fact that most of
Christendom was conquered and swallowed
up. Um, and it's, you know, there's a
there's a lesson in that because if it
happened before, it can happen again.
And it did continue happening. We forget
Spain was conquered for centuries, the
Balkans, all of Eastern Europe, all the
Mediterranean islands, Rome was sacked
in 846. Muslim pirates went all the way
as far as Iceland, virtually no corner
was uh, you know, left untouched by this
jihad that went on. The United States of
America's first war as a nation was with
Muslims from North Africa, Barbrey
pirates who were enslaving um American
sailors. When they met with Jefferson,
they basically told him, "Yeah, it's our
religion, our Quran. Our prophet says
you're the infidel." And uh you know,
they went they literally paraphrased
that Quran verse I told you, Quran 95,
which basically says um lay in wait and
ambush and and attack and enslave and
kill the polytheists wherever you find
them. That's exactly what um the
ambassador for Barbrey told Jefferson.
Uh even though you know Jefferson didn't
put quotes on it but as I read it his
own words he was literally quoting that
verse. Um yeah so so a huge chunk of
Christianity was permanently conquered
and um and the rest continued to be
infiltrated till this day.
>> You know I I think a lot of people ask
why why did this religion take off so
quickly? Why was it so appealing? And
you talk a bit in in the beginning about
tribalism and how basically Muhammad
deified tribalism. So the elements of
tribalism, you know, there's us, there's
them, the enemy, and then and then you
can go sack the enemy. Those those three
things which seem to be popular or are
the essence of of tribal people. What
Muhammad did was he deified this or gave
license to do it. And then you have this
going on. Is that is does that explain
help explain because people always ask
how did this thing take off so quickly
you know?
>> Yeah that is actually the way I see it
um exactly the way you said it. He took
he took the normal tribal mores of of
his society which were very and
tribalism is actually more natural to
humans than what we have in the west.
What we have is is learned behavior.
It's good. It's uh people can live
together but tribalism is sort of the
default human mode. um which as you
described it us against them. We are the
the people. The others are all enemies
who exist for us to plunder, kill.
They're always en they're enemies by
nature and the other tribe sees you that
way. It's understood. And so he took
that idea and infused it with Islam. So
now it was no longer blood kin. It was
the the believers, the um as it's
called, the Muslims. And they are all
collectively one group. And now the
entire world that's not Muslim is the
other group, the other tribe that just
exists to be attacked. And what's
interesting about that is if you look at
the peoples who did convert in mass to
Islam, they were all inherently tribal
in nature. So first the Arabs of course
and then afterwards you have Berbers in
North Africa who become the Moors. Then
you have the Turks and then you have M
segments of the Mongols, the Tatars as
they were were called. All of these
groups were inherently tribalistic. And
so I think the the message of Islam was
very natural and appealing to them
because it was basically basically said
you can continue living your way of life
praying on the other, killing,
slaughtering, raping, uh plundering, but
now you get to go to heaven doing that
because now they're infidels. You're
believers. You're good. They're evil. Um
and uh so I think that's why it was very
appealing to those types of people.
Um, you talked about in the Quran 9:29,
the eternal war on Christian, you know,
how how basically for a lot of our
listeners, we want to know back then
there's three or back then or even now
there's three choices it seems. If
you're Christian, is that correct? When
the when the Muslims come in and take
over, you basically only have three
choices.
>> Yeah. According to Quran 9:29, and it's
even elaborated in certain hadith, but
it's basically um yeah, you either
convert as a Christian or a Jew. people
of the book uh or you pay tribute jiza
and you live and you embrace secondass
status within an Islamic polity, you
accept that you're going to be a
secondass citizen. It's openly
acknowledged um you embrace that um and
you pay the tribute or you fight to the
death. So those were the three choices.
Convert, submit or fight.
>> You know, I I thought it was interesting
you had a couple endotes.
um in the book which I I found
fascinating where the early Christians
saw the Arabs as as demons um I think it
was John of John of Bostonra
interrogated
um three demonically possessed women who
said that they align themselves is that
correct more with the demons speaking
through the women said that they align
themselves more with the Arabs is that
correct from John Abra
>> yeah yeah the early Christians
definitely had a different take on how
they understood and registered events.
Um, and to them they understood demons,
hated everything sacred, hated churches,
hated icons, hated crosses, hated the
Eucharist, hated all that, you know,
everything that was traditionally sacred
from a Christian point of view. And lo
and behold, these Arabs just come out of
nowhere, out of Arabia, out of the
deserts and start intentionally
attacking and desecrating everything uh
like that. So that was very much seen as
they were um animated by some sort of
diabolical animus um you know manifest
through these humans coming out of the
desert. And it also makes sense because
Islam is not just a religion out to
conquer. It explicitly condemns
Christian ideas and um you know cardinal
ideas that Jesus is a son of God that he
was crucified that he was resurrected.
Okay. So that's why they break the
cross. It's a very famous saying amongst
Muslims to break the cross reportedly
tracing back to Muhammad. ISIS would
regularly post you know uh use that
phrase and engage in that behavior as do
Muslims elsewhere all around the world
where they habitually break crosses um
and desecrate churches. So for early
Christians it was uh you know they
understood what was really going on.
you know, uh the the first battle and
and I encourage people get the book read
about this. I it's amazing how many
people I talk to about this book and and
you they have no idea about a lot of
these battles and these are pretty
educated people. Um but the battle of
Yarmmuk you referred to as perhaps the
most or they referred to as perhaps the
most consequential battle in history.
That's quite a statement, you know. Um,
is there is there what what is the
reason that might be called the mo or is
referred to as the most consequential
battle?
>> Right. Well, that is a that's actually a
direct quotation um from a historian um
Francisco Gabrieli, I believe, probably
wrote around the 60s. Um an orientalist
um and that's actually what first piqued
my interest about the battle of Yarmmuk,
which is why I subsequently wrote my
thesis about it is after I read that
phrase where he said this was the most
consequential battle in world history.
Um, and the reason is is because it it
was that battle that really broke um the
the back of the Roman army, the
Christian or what we call the Byzantine
army um which was at the time ruling
Egypt as it did in Syria. And um so the
battle of Yarmmuk is in Syria along the
Yarmmuk River. And um it was a very
consequential battle in that the Muslims
won. They were actually outnumbered. And
there's all different theories of what
happened which I go into in my thesis
gets pretty academic and dry possibly
but um the long and short of it is they
prevailed they won and after that it was
kind of like a domino thing. So right
after the battle of Yarmuk in 636
Jerusalem was conquered um from
Christendom and by 640 641 Egypt was
conquered. Um, so it was it was seen as
that was the reason that the Muslim
conquest that I just told you, you know,
conquered uh 66% of the Christian world.
That's why it happened because of that
particular battle. So that's why it's
very consequential and decisive because
if they could have been beaten at at
Yarmmoo, who knows, history could have
changed. You know, the the spread of
Islam could have um halted. It could
have stayed just in Arabia. Um, you
know, that's one of those what if
questions, but it's well known that
right after Yarmmuk and a little before
there was another pivotal battle in 634
that those battles, but especially
Yarmmuk completely just opened the way
for this sort of domino effect of the
Arab conquests further west.
>> You know, I have to say after reading
that, I I have to confess I'm still
puzzled why the Christians lost that
battle. I think that dust storm had
something to do with it. I really gut
instinct tells me that dust storm had
something to do with it. But but I I
encourage the listeners to read about it
because it's a it's a very depressing
battle because I keep thinking we're
going to win it as I read it and
something goes wrong. But you brought up
two other points I want to quickly touch
on before we move on is uh you talked
about after that a lot of people don't
realize the entire north of Africa I
guess in the next 70 years was
completely taken over and and you talked
about and you you used Egypt as an
example. Egypt was a primarily Christian
nation. And how when the Arabs took
over, even though the Egyptian
Christians were the minority, this use
of this demi when you become a secondass
citizen is so harsh that eventually they
just capitulate over time and it becomes
and it becomes a Muslim nation, you
know. And and the other thing I I was
hoping you touch on is you talked about
a bit you made the analogy at the
Germanic tribes in Europe when they
conquered nations. They they they did
two things. They adopted the the local
language over time and the religion the
Christian religion as opposed to the
Arabs who conquered these places,
brought their religion and never and
never adopted the language. I think you
mentioned that's why there's 22
Arab-speaking nations to this day. So um
>> yeah, exactly. Um and so going back to
that system which I described where uh
you can be a Christian or a Jew and pay
tribute according to Quran 9:29. Well
the reality of that system is okay let's
say initially a a lot of let's say
Christians of Egypt or wherever agreed
to it. But first of all, you have to
have money because they literally there
is passages in the Islamic text where
the khalif tells the governor of Egypt,
you know, milk them like like cows for
every until they milk until they give
out blood, meaning extort them of every
last penny you can. So initially a lot
of them had no money, the peasants, and
they all just immediately became
converts. Um and then as years go by and
decades go by, it becomes harder and
harder for you know the regular people
who are Christians to maintain their
faith. It's just so much easier not to
pay and not to and also to become equal
as a Muslim. Okay. So there so that was
an intentional pressure that is part of
the Islamic system. It's it's a win-win.
You know, as long as you stay as a
infidel, as a Christian, we'll take your
money and abuse you and um until you get
sick of it and then you become one of
us. So, it's it's just a complete
win-win. And if you look at the history
and the progression of um these various
Christian nations that were conquered by
Islam, you'll see a slow motion change
demographically of Christians becoming
Muslims. As late as uh you know, as late
as, let's say, the 10th century in
Egypt, which was conquered in the
seventh, it's it seems according to
scholars that it was still
overwhelmingly Christian and still
overwhelmingly Coptic. Um but then you
and then you would also have not just
you have to pay all this tribute but you
would also have depending on the khif
the whims of whichever khalif it was or
sultan later on um there would be just
mass pograms and massacres of Christians
and uprisings. So for example under the
the Fatimid Khalif in Egypt Hakim Umbra
Allah there was all sorts of extreme
persecution of Christians according to
their own sources Islamic chronicles
30,000 churches were destroyed again
that shows you how Christian Egypt and
greater Syria the Middle East were um
and the sorts of sporadic persecutions
that were unleashed upon them above and
beyond having to pay tribute uh and live
like like I said secondass demies which
itself is not enviable and which itself
caused a lot of Christians to eventually
abandon and apostasize and embrace Islam
and if you look at it um so places like
in North Africa okay like Hippo where
Augustine comes from
>> St. Augustine they were you know
complete total hubs of Christianity I
think in that same area North Africa was
one of the major councils of the church
where the Bible as we have it was
codified I want to say in the sixth
century um so you know how but now if
you look at al Algeria and Libya and
these countries there are no indigenous
Christians if there are they're usually
you know they're first of all in hiding
and they were converted by western
missionaries but even though it wasn't
originally they had indigenous
Christians, they're gone. And then the
most populous and essentially the most
powerful Christian region, which was
Egypt, it's now down to, depending on
who you ask, it could be anywhere from 8
to 12% Christian. Okay? From essentially
100%. And um I quote I think one of
these um Alfred Butler I believe he's a
historian and he really makes what I'm
telling you in a in a he really says in
a very good articulate way about how you
know yeah you could pay and buy your
religion as a dimmi but realistically
this could only last for so long and
with each passing decade and century
more and more people would enter into
the house of Islam and that's why it was
eventually snuffed out in North Africa
and that's why it's on its way to being
snuffed out in a place like Egypt. Uh so
because a lot of people like to tell me
oh you know look at Egypt there's still
10% you know uh cops there then doesn't
that prove Islam is uh merciful and
tolerant
>> and no it doesn't based on what I just
explained these conversions happened due
to duress and coercion
if there was no you have to pay money to
keep your religion and you have to be
treated as a secondass citizen I think
these countries would have been
Christian majority but yeah there's
there's all these mechanisms that
pressure people uh to leave the religion
unlike other religions like Christianity
okay where you have freedom of religion
let's say today in the west so and the
other point about uh the Germanic tribes
exactly even you know they came in and
conquered the Roman Empire which was
Christian at the time but they are the
ones who assimilated into the Latin
world basically um so they you know they
became Christians they took their their
languages were infused with the Latin
alphabet took on Latin words became you
know members of the church at the time
and that's how it's so different with
Islam because Islam went into the older
Christian territory and it forced it to
change according to its whim its whims
and its teachings.
>> Yeah. I and you know I that that battle
uh when we go back to Yarmach was for a
Christian side very depressing. I think
the next one you talk about the siege of
Constantinople which interestingly took
place exactly over one year I think
April 15th to April 15th which I found
fascinating was really um as I read the
chapter let's put it in the New York way
a whopping um for for this side but what
I found fascinating which was a
recurring theme I wanted to talk about
was the lore and and the lore of jihad
and it seems a big inspiration as I read
chapter after chapter um I make notes in
books and I kept writing the word yesesh
you know like uh was this the sexual
assaults
um the lore of let's say white European
women and and just the attraction of
this seemed to be a constant impetus to
propel the uh the jihad it was
constantly like if you you called it the
win-win situation so if you go attack
this place. Either you're going to die
in I think you called the the Horries
they were called the H.
>> Yeah. Horries, which I found very
interesting. Either that or you're going
to be to sack and pillage this place. So
either way, you're going to be having a
good time. Um so you know before just
talking about Constantinople, is that
what you refer to as the lure or of
jihad?
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's what I call the
win-win situation of jihad. Like I I
more generically explained it earlier
when I said tribal peoples continued
living tribally, which is I pray on the
other because everyone who's not part of
my tribe is the other. I kill them, I
rape them, I enslave them, I plunder
them. That's the general gist of it. And
um and now with Islam, I still do that,
but now I'm the good guy. I'm pious and
I go to heaven. Um, and so what you're
referring to is a more kind of honed in
version of that concept of win-win which
was so one of them one of the the things
if you want to talk about booty human
booty human blunt plunder was of course
that according to the Quran that it's
completely legitimate to sexually
enslave infidel women during war during
jihad. That's all over the Quran. In
fact, they don't they're the the pronoun
used to describe them is such that
they're not even humans. They're like a
possession, a thing. They're called that
that thing which your right hand
possesses. Okay, which the Islamic
jurists all interpret as meaning females
plundered um uh taken in war, captives,
infidels, and um so you have that on the
one hand. On the other hand, Muhammad's
paradise. So if you die trying to get
these uh women or whatever plunder, if
you die, then you get all that in
heaven. It's a very carnal and fleshy
heaven. Um and not only do you get women
in heaven, but you actually get
supernatural women who are described as
those are the hurries. Um they're called
which means something it means like they
have a very like black pupil and white
iris. Um you know, but they're very
supernatural. their their breasts are
described and uh you know they exist
just to sexually satisfy Allah's
favorites his martyrs in perpetuity and
all kinds of lurid and weird things are
in the hadith like uh you know you you
de virginize them because they're all
virgins and then their hyman grows back
so you can keep doing it over and over
okay so that's uh that that's what I
mean by the win-win mentality uh so if
you can get it here in the now fine and
if you can if you don't well well you'll
even get it more forever in eternity.
And this is why, by the way, and I spent
some time talking about how early
Christians who, you know, got a hold of
the Quran and and all the other writings
of Islam were completely scandalized.
And to them, it was just such a
outrageous religion. You know, I'm
thinking of someone like Theophanes, the
Confessor in the 8th century, um, who
who we get a lot of information, um,
regarding the siege of Constantinople
you're referring to. I mean, he just
says, you know, he the way he describes
it, he's like, "This this is ridiculous
that this religion that these that this
man said this, that their heaven is just
a brothel, basically." Um, and so many
others, John of
>> Food, too. I think you you said there's
a lot of food up there, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Food. You can drink alcohol
even though you can't drink it here.
There's rivers of wine.
>> Rivers of wine, you know?
>> Right.
>> So, it it it's it's made to entice the
carnal man. But then also, you know, I
think this is what you were getting to
in that chapter is white women and
there's a long history uh which traces
back to Muhammad as usual of um Muslims
essentially targeting white women for
sexual enslavement. Um they would fetch
a very high price on the slave market.
Muhammad in another hadith um he
basically this is one of the early
campaigns that he wanted to do is called
the campaign of Tabuk where supposedly
he was he was going to raid um
Byzantines which would be Eastern
European type looking people and he's
trying to you know um he's trying to
entice men to follow him and join this
campaign because they're afraid this is
the Roman army it's not just a another
Arab tribe we're going to raid and he
tells them well don't you want the in
Arabic it says the people of fellow but
it's understood like it means either the
fairhaired or fair skinned people right
and and he talks and and they talk about
one man's like yes don't tempt me oh
prophet of Allah I love those women
and but you get that sort of thing all
throughout in the history in sword and
scimitar I I document it keeps popping
up during sader era it was also you know
they talk they fantasize and about like
Frankish women European women
>> and um yeah so it was definitely a thing
And um it was also part of that win-win
mentality.
>> Um just to quickly go over that uh siege
of Constantinople, it what I found
amazing in your description was how many
things were happening to the Muslim
army. I mean, we're talking about the
Greek fire. Uh you talked about um they
were vastly outnumbered. But in addition
to that, uh you're there was a disease,
a long winter. You also had the um
storms, volcanoes. This one didn't seem
to be going the way of the Muslims in in
this battle. Would that be a fair
statement?
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's an important battle.
I think it was it's it I put it in the
book. It's considered very decisive
because that wasn't the first um assault
on Constantinople. There was a a much
longer siege right around the time of
the great Arab conquest when Egypt had
fallen, Iran, Persia had fallen. they
they did besiege Constantinople in the
se 650s um and it didn't didn't work and
so this time it was a really massive
campaign that the Khif sent and it was a
kind of like a do or die and they were
convinced they were going to win and
they could have but you know thank there
was all sorts of like you mentioned all
sorts of factors that arose including
the general who became the emperor
Heraclus um and also yes nature famine
amongst the Muslims and and storm storms
and snow, all of that really came into
play. But historians have also talked
about that siege that had they won at
that time because this is the time of
the peak of the Arab conquest when
everything is falling down. You know, I
mean 50 years after after or a little
before that is when all of North Africa
had been conquered and they had already
uh just um uh six years before that
siege they had already conquered Spain.
So this is the you know the peak of the
Arab conquest and it's believed that if
they had conquered Constantinople then
then they would have started flooding
into Europe from the eastern doorway
Constantinople. So that's why that's
another very decisive moment and they
eventually did do that but uh about 700
years later
>> right and and you you know you next go
into what I I think a lot of people
don't realize you we talk about which
it's popular these days the battle of
tours
>> uh 732 but I don't think a lot of people
realize that the Muslim armies were
knocking at the door of France um I I
think these were the Berbers is that
correct mostly the Berbers um And
I think people when when I've mentioned
that to some people, they they don't
think that Muslims ever entered Europe.
They they're shocked to hear that. But
the fact is if if there was no Charles
Martell and this we might be facing a
different different Europe. So could you
just quickly tell a little bit about
what why again again these are all
consequential battles or they wouldn't
be there, but this one seems to be a big
one and I see it's in the media a lot
these days.
Yeah, this one is important and it's it
tends to be pretty iconic and f popular
amongst Western people because it
directly impacts Western Europe. It's
one of the few battles that uh directly
impacted because it was literally in the
heart of France and that's about as far
west um or northwest they already
further west as Spain if you want to
look at a map but further that's the as
far as they had gone into the heart of
Europe from from the west um and and
that was and what's interesting about
that date also is um so Muhammad dies in
632 one century later is the battle of
Quatier or Tors in 732 and it's in that
century where all those massive
conquests of a massive chunk the the
majority of Christendom happened and it
and it was at that battle so literally
100 years after Muhammad's death is when
it finally stops from entering further
penetrating further west um at the hands
of Charles Martell so again it's one of
those battles that had it failed um
because it was a massive Muslim army it
was still a Muslim Arabled army and it
was Berbers and the Berbers have their
own interesting story because they're
from North Africa and they resisted
Islam for as long as they could. They
fought back uh for a couple of decades
until they finally just gave up and
became part of the tribe and then
interestingly once they became Muslims
then they became Muslims and they
started attacking the other and now you
know even though they were suffering
from Islam a decade earlier here they
are in Europe.
>> Yeah. Terrorizing others in the name of
Islam. Um but yeah, it's believed that
had it succeeded then there's good
reason to believe Gibbon, Edward Gibbon,
the historian
famously said something which I'm
paraphrasing about how had it had
Charles Martell not stopped them then
the Quran would be taught in Oxford and
um little does he know that it is now
taught in Oxford
>> that's the prime book taught in Oxford
so I hear these days you know
>> exactly
>> you know you you also mentioned in the
same chapter how the Mediterranean at
this point because everyone's busy
celebrating this, but the Mediterranean
basically had turned into a Muslim lake
um at this point. Uh and I don't think
people realize how bad things were, you
know, in the Mediterranean at this
point. In fact, uh you mentioned
something I found very interesting that
the dark ages perhaps uh started because
of that. Could you tell us what what was
going on in this Muslim lake known as
the Mediterranean?
>> Right. So again, if you go back before
the Islamic conquest, and I'm speaking
about the whole of Christendom, the
majority of it is, like I said, uh in
Europe, it's only basically southwest of
the Danube and Ry. Okay? And um and then
it's all of North Africa and the Middle
East and Asia Minor. And so that's
because the older, richer,
more, you know, progressive, believe it
or not, region was North Africa and the
Middle East. Um I mean that's why
Constantine for example moved the
capital to the east to Constantinople
Nova Roma which he founded and built um
then in the early 4th century. And so
when when all that was conquered and
swallowed up in the Mediterranean, which
was just really a highway of commerce
between Europe and North Africa, cuz
they were all one overarching
civilization, Christians, all under Rome
at the time, um until the the barbarian
invasions, but even that, like we said,
that didn't change the um the face of
things at that much. The or the essence
anyway, the the Christianity. Um so
because all that region got conquered
and Islamized basically Europe Christian
Europe was more was kind of like the the
the the little brother now left to fend
on him on his own. Okay. Again, this is
hard for people to understand because
they think Christianity, Christendom,
medieval era, Europe alone, and then the
rest is, you know, well, no, this is now
and this is so there's a reason that the
dark ages, as they were called,
historians now don't like to talk about
that for various reasons, but what was
called the dark ages really comes around
um you know, after after the this
sundering of Islam. uh this all these
conquests are what the 600s and then in
732 they're in France. Well, the dark
ages are seen right around then the late
700s you know the year 800 Charlemagne
crowned Holy Roman Emperor. A lot of
people date that as the beginning of the
dark ages. Um so a lot was happening.
There were attacks from Vikings. People
recognize that there were attacks from
you know Huns from the east. um Maguars,
Avars and uh but the main thrust was
really what was happening from the major
conquest which like I said swallowed up
most of Christendom cut off Europe by
taking over the Mediterranean. Things
like um learning and illiteracy dropped
right away in Europe because all the
papy used to come from Egypt which was
now no longer uh in commerce with Europe
as one example. And these are the things
that um Henry Pyin talks about in his in
his book uh Charlemagne and Muhammad
where he basically says there is no
Charlemagne without Muhammad that Islam
basically gave rise to feudalism in the
dark age. Um there there's a reason that
people fled the coasts and went into the
highlands and it was because Muslim
pirates were constantly raiding coastal
regions of Europe because they had
conquered the Mediterranean islands. Um,
so that was a known thesis by by that
particular orientalist historian. And
again, for obvious reasons, it's been
sort of suppressed and censored and kind
of like dismissed. It's not worth even
talking about. Um, but again, it it it
makes sense when one puts it in context.
>> Yeah. No, and I'm glad we are talking
about it because people need to hear
about these things. Um you you talk
about the battle of Manzacert um after
this and and um I found this I found
this battle interesting in that this
really was you know we think we all
think of Turkey today as Muslim you know
this is a Muslim place but that's that's
not the case or was we Anatolia at the
time and and this is am I correct this
is when the the Seljic Turks moved um
moved east and basically took over the
peninsula is that why this was such a
seinal battle,
>> right? The the the battle of Manziker is
seinal and um important and I included
it in sword and scimitar because for for
many reasons first it's the first major
victory of the new power of Islam at the
time the Seljic Turks. Uh now by by this
time this is the 11th century and um the
Arabs are their power is waning now.
It's the Abbassad caliphate. It's not
expanding the way its predecessor the
Umayads did. during those um what we
were talking about those massive
conquests and um the the Turks come in
from the east and they because like I
told you because they're tribal they've
they took to Islam like you know fish
and water it was very normal to them. In
fact it's interesting because I talk
about their oldest oral traditions and
you can compare them when they're pagans
and what they say and then you compare
them when they become Muslims and all
that's changed is just you know the
wording. So goes from I I conquered my
foe and took his pretty girls and uh
whatever to oh I conquered the infidel
and took his women and burned the cross
and I said Allah abbar so um that's also
interesting but it was during this time
then you know you you have like what you
can call a second major wave of Islamic
jihadist hostility against Christian
regions with these Turks who start
pouring in especially into Asia Minor
and Anatolia and they engage in extreme
horrific atrocities. And because the
records we have are closer to our time
than the 7th century. Okay, we we have
for example Matthew Adessa who is
essentially a near contemporary and he
talks about tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands over these decades
starting around 1019 up until the battle
of Mantacer 1071 where Armenians
especially because Asia Minor had was
greater Armenia was a very much larger
Armenian territory of just being
butchered, enslaved, thousands of their
churches being desoiled, burnt, crosses
being broken, the same sort of diabolic
ical animus was also on display then and
then with the battle of Manzuker this is
when again the Roman Empire the
Byzantines went out in a massive army
it's not unlike Yarmmuk actually because
they outnumbered the the Muslims the
Turks but for again various reasons
which I get into in the book the Turks
won um and completely
>> I think you called it the Turkish
Yarmmuk. Yes.
>> Yeah. Exactly. It strikes me as as like
the Turkish equivalent of the battle of
Yarmmuk for the Arabs. very very similar
and a lot of this for those who are
interested in strategy and and
maneuvering it has to do with the light
cavalry of Muslims, horsemen, Arabs and
Turks uh compared to you know the heavy
heavy formations of Western infantry men
uh which sometimes were good but often
times the Muslims knew how to they would
gain they would engage in fign retreats
and then kind of break up their lines
and surround them with and use tons and
tons of arrows which at the time Western
Europeans saw as very dishonorable way
of warfare because the knight liked to
fight, you know, hand-to-hand combat. It
was seen as only cowards, use arrows. Uh
but of course, the Islamic way of war
was almost completely based on light
infantry, uh light cavalry, sorry,
horsemen. Anyway, they win. And it was
at that point after that battle because
they they decisively defeat defeated the
Byzantines that then they really took
over all of Asia Minor. And it was a
wash with even more atrocities than
before.
>> Yeah. I think you mentioned a also a lot
of the best farmland and also you said
the best soldiers were coming from that
area. Is that correct?
>> Yeah. Asia Minor Anatolia is it's a very
ancient Christian region very yeah very
sturdy hearty you know fighters and not
a few emperors came from there as well.
I mean it was a major loss to lose all
that and um you know in fact that's what
propelled again most people don't
realize this is what propelled the first
crusade because we're now close to it
1071 and 1095 is the first call to the
crusade
>> I think you said they called it that
terrible day is that correct
>> that dreadful day or terrible day
>> day that was the beginning of the end um
you know leading as you said this seemed
to lead into the crusades and you talk
about in your next chapter the battle of
Hatim. Um, and we're talking about here
the Crusades. And I I think a lot of
people don't realize how much
persecution was going on for pilgrims
coming to see Jerusalem at this time in
the 1000s. How much persecution uh was
going on. And and and also you mentioned
it's the first time that the Christian
armies start to and the Christian forces
to go on the offensive as opposed to the
defensive.
>> Yeah. And that's the and that's why we
all know about the Crusades because
finally we we found in all this history
Christians moving out of their territory
to fight Muslims. And finally we found
that. But now we're going to talk only
about that. We're going to pull it out
of context. We're not going to talk
about all that I've I've said led up to
this.
>> And we're going to show you how horrible
the Crusades and Europeans were because
that's what most people now know. That's
all they know. They know the Crusades
just happened. They have they they don't
believe I've quoted this a million
times. There's a professor John Espazito
uh he wrote in one of his books um Islam
the straight path. He says five
centuries of peaceful coexistence
between Muslims and Christians elapsed
until the first crusade came and ruined
it all.
>> Amazing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. That's what's
called scholarship.
>> Just considering what you said happened
in Anatolia. And I remember when reading
that chapter you wrote I I really my jaw
dropped. I mean what was happening in
Anatolia you I mean we're throwing out
numbers of 10,000 100 thousand like it's
nothing and and and this this continued
on and on and I encourage people out
there to read the book because really
your jaw is going to drop at what you're
hearing and I do like in in this chapter
you talked about some wonderful
wonderful guys. I loved uh your
description. Well I like Tank. He's a
fantastic guy. But probably my favorite
was Bohiman, this magnificent soldier.
And I love the the end note where the
princess described him as a a giant with
huge muscles and charm, but with a
general heir of the horrible. I said
that was just a wonderful description.
>> But uh these guys had a powerful force
going out there.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I mean the the crusaders
were an admirable and powerful titanic
force to be reckoned with and that they
actually won the first crusade which
itself was seen as a miracle that you
know a small group would travel
thousands of miles right into the heart
of enemy territory without any
meaningful logistics and you know about
halfway through they're already starving
um and and being you know attacked by
disease and famine and dissentry
and wild animals attacking them. Okay.
and killing them. So it was seen as a
miracle that they actually won and it's
a testimony to their stalwart nature.
But yeah, now now you now we know what
the origin of the first crusade was and
why it happened because word came to the
western Christians of the the complete
atrocities that were happening
especially following menac and they were
engaged in all sorts of hor horrific
they would you know they describe how
they would find a priest and you know
cut open his stomach pull his endrails
out tie it to a pillar and whip him
until he runs around the pillar and and
>> I mean really that's just one of many
examples of the sorts of things they
were engaged in. So now you know why the
first crusade happened. We never hear
this part. We never hear that the
western European Christians were
outraged and shocked to hear this was
happening to their co-religionists by
the infidel by the Muslim. Okay. So
that's that now it makes sense why they
went where they went. It wasn't about uh
what they try to tell us, you know, um
going and conquering land and carving a
new kingdom for yourself. If that was
the case, why not do it somewhere else
locally? Why if you why why travel and
suffer like I said thousands of miles
the way they did and sell your property
and your land to raise money to go
>> at low cost. You mentioned at low cost.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. So that was it.
And then you know the whole crusader
history for anyone who's interested I
really get I do a very very deep dive
into the Crusades in my most recent
book, The Two Swords of Christ because
it's about the military orders. And um
>> just so everyone knows I just got my
copy about my got it for my birthday.
So, I'm back.
>> Awesome. Awesome. And that book is uh
it's about the military orders, but
because the military orders were so
central to the Crusades, it's really a
it's my deepest dive into the Crusades.
I think it's over 500 pages. So, I am
only saying that because um in Sword and
Scimitar, I talk briefly about the
Crusade, then I focus on the Battle of
Hatton because it's mostly about
decisive battles, right?
>> And that is decisive decisive because
that's what really puts an end to the
Crusades. I mean they continue for
almost a century or even more than a
century but it's sort of the beginning
of the end okay where Saladin defeats
them again another massive Christian
army uh against smaller but fast swift
Muslim horsemen a lot of devious PS the
hot desert sun I think it was in July
4th and you got these guys wearing 80
pounds of armor in you know in in the
deserts of Judea walking around like
that. Um, so they lost and uh it was
again the beginning of the end for uh
the Holy Land.
>> I I think I encourage people this this
this was one of my favorite chapters.
You did a great job with the
descriptions. Um I never the you know
what always would come up is the
suffering. I mean this eating of shoes
and drinking of horse blood you know was
uh you know it's just amazing for for
our spoiled modern world to see what
suffering uh was going on in the name of
Christianity. I mean we have a uh you
know a modern population that almost is
cynical uh of the motivations but what
I've seen here is these were pure
motivations.
uh they you know they believed in their
religion and they believed in this and
and no one would endure that otherwise
and and it you know it is really amazing
one theme in this chapter is how much
they suffered and how heroic these men
were. Yeah,
>> that's the irony that when you look at
something like the Crusades, it was
actually a war. It was it was a journey
of love and altruism and that's how it
was seen. Okay, these were men who were
essentially sacrificing their lives to
go help defend other Christians and to
recover holy sacred land and holy sight
uh holy sites. It was actually
altruistic and idealistic unlike our
wars. Our wars are very cynical, very
destructive,
>> full of lies. And it's ironic to me
because it's the people who would
promote our wars that love to talk about
how evil the crusaders were. Okay. So,
you know, good's been turned into evil
and evil into good. Talking about that,
Spain, which amazing a lot of people
don't know, you talk about the battle of
La Navasta Tlosa 1212 and how Spain was
occupied for almost 800 years. Um, I
think it was invaded in 7-Eleven you
mentioned, which is astoundingly early
considering the, you know, the death of
Muhammad was what, 632, I believe. 632.
So, to be knocking on the door and
invading Spain, but um, could you just
tell a little bit about how like what
happened and how so quickly this
country, Spain, is taken over?
>> Well, it was part of that, you know,
when I was talking about from the death
of Muhammad 632 to the battle of Tor
732, it was in 7-Eleven. So it was part
of that dramatic first century conquest
um all of North Africa in the Middle
East and into Spain and finally stopping
in the middle of France. Okay. So that's
why it fell very quickly. But as you
indicated, it really became to me it's
to me it's kind of a microcosm of the
whole book sword and scimitar because
it's just a very focused peninsula and
you have one portion is Christian, one
portion is Muslim and they are
continuously waring constantly
especially in the reconista because
finally there was always a small holdup
group of Christians in northwest
quadrant of the peninsula.
>> Po
great guy. Great guy. I mean, I I still
don't know what they were eating in
those mountains, but I just to tell the
people out there, you got to read this
chapter because his
>> his uh kingdom of Atoria that he set up
there. I've been up there on travels and
and seen it. You call it the mustard
seed is is really amazing what he did up
there.
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's that's its own story
right there where basically Yeah. after
the Christians capitulated and fell to
Islam in 7-Eleven, a little afterwards,
he he basically rallied a group of men
and people who refused to live under
Islamic tyranny and lived in the
mountains. And the Muslims even said,
"Oh, leave them." You know, they you
were asking what they eat. They said,
"Oh, they just live on honey. They're
they're nothing to reckon with." But you
know decade after decade, century after
century from that which was called this
the mustard seed based on the biblical
parable of Christ you know something
small that grows into something big. So
from there it snowballed in time into
what's known as the reconista. And so
the Christians from that region in the
north started slowly driving southward
and reconquering uh Spain and Portugal.
>> This battle was a crusade. Correct. the
battle of the pope had organized it. I
think I think you mentioned there were
30,000 Frenchmen and then when there was
no caviar they they abandoned ship or
something.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
Well, well, you know, again, in keeping
with the idea that it's a microcosm of
of the Crusades, actually, a lot of the
um ideas of the crusade and some would
even argue actual they they started in
Spain and also by Pope Urban II um where
I think he would give indulgences and
and again invoke crusader terminology
while talking to the Christians of Spain
before the first crusade. um because
they were dealing with the Islamic
problem even before in Europe. In fact,
there were there were popes who would
sometimes ban Spaniards from crusading
in the Holy Land because they had their
own crusade and they had to stay there
uh because that was also seen as a
crusade. And yes, 1212 that battle
basically was again the where where the
Muslim powers had finally broke and
after that it all started you know just
year after year. So by basically
something like 1250 um Islam is now just
in Granada the the very tiny tip of
southern uh of the of the peninsula and
though they stay there for almost for
about two centuries or actually more
than two centuries mostly because the
Christians were okay with it mostly
because it wasn't that easy it was a
very remote fat you know mountainous
area that is not easily conquered um but
yeah and and then there's a whole
chapter which I get into about you know
how the Muslims finally when they were
so outnumbered and completely lost. Then
they all agreed to convert to
Christianity, but it was a ruse. It was
a lie. I want to just mention that
because that I think for the modern day
that that term um tea is very important
because you talked about the Mauriceos
uh which I was a very interesting name
but a lot of people don't realize that
the Muslims at that time you know as you
said when they're outnumbered said okay
we're going to convert and they even
went to mass did all of that but because
of this concept tea they were able to do
that so this concept of tequila, what
what exactly is it?
>> Right? So, the concept of tea, which is
interesting because it comes up today, I
I wrote one of the oldest um articles
about it many years ago and um it's
basically this idea that it it's it's a
doctrine in Islam and it has Quranic
backing. Usually, one of the main verses
is 328. Long and short of it is a Muslim
is permitted to pretend to anything. He
can pretend he became a Christian. he
could pretend to renounce and even curse
Muhammad as long as in his heart he's
still a Muslim and he's doing this as a
way to help Islam um or help himself
against the infidel and so uh one of the
most memorable anecdotes and again this
is a perfect example of how history has
been distorted you always hear about you
know the Christians how the evil
monarchy and how they drove out Jews and
Muslims and um in 1492 and the evil
inquisition
And the idea is that, you know, these
were just intolerant Christians who
couldn't live in peace with Muslims and
and Jews. They just had to make them
just like them. Well, when you dig into
the sources, it's a little different.
You find out that the Muslims were
continued had pretended to become
Christians, but were actually actively
working against the Christian uh Spain
and Portugal. They were allying with the
Barbrey pirates. They were allying with
the Ottomans. whenever they they could,
they would engage in horrific atrocities
and uprisings against Christians. And
that's what led to the Inquisition
because they said they're Christian.
They uh converted openly. They parttook
of communion. They went to church. They
read the Bible. And um so the
Inquisition was basically well, if there
how can we tell who's a real Christian
and who's not actually a faker in doing
this? That was actually the origins of
how all this started. Um again, so which
is not convenient to mention. Um and the
Jews also got mixed up into it often
because they were helping the Muslims.
They actually did um historically this
is well known that um from a historical
point of view usually the Jews would
actually side with Muslims. They helped
them enter Spain actually um and it's
very famous you know who opened the go
the gates of Toledo and that sort of
thing but it happened elsewhere too. So
that's really the origins of the
Inquisition of why it wasn't Christians
insisting you have to be like us. We
don't believe in diversity. It was you
guys are pretending to be like us, which
means we're supposed to live with you
openly, but you're actually lying and
you're doing this to hurt us.
>> Okay, that that's how it was understood.
And there's I I quote, you know,
documents, people saying these people
were better Christians than us.
>> Yes. you know, and they did it
generation after generation, but then in
their hearts they were essentially like
ISIS. Imagine that. So, yeah, that's
what led to um the Inquisition.
>> We moved on to the siege of
Constantinople, a depressing chapter for
me when I was reading it 1453. I do, you
know, uh this was for the readers out
there, this was the Ottoman Turks. Now,
not the Seljic, the Ottoman Turks moved
in. I found the descriptions um and the
endnotes very interesting this chapter
especially there was uh just before the
battle there's some I I encourage people
to read the chapter that there was a
three-hour eclipse I think on May 24th
and then you said on May 27th there was
a strange fog and a light over Haga
Sophia that disappeared and it was cited
by both the Christians and um and the
Muslim armies which said perhaps the
Holy Spirit was leaving the Haga Sophia
but this was this was didn't turn out
very well for the Christian uh armies is
it and uh well for Christendom shall we
say? Uh
>> yeah, so the the fall of Constantinople
is definitely one of the most iconic in
a negative way uh jihads and and losses
for Christendom. And I think you know
the reason when you read it and other
people read it it's very you know they
tell me it's so tra traumatizing. It's
because it's not because it was worse
than other jihad jihadist sacks. It's
because it happened in the 15th century
and as it happens we have a lot more
records from the 15th century than we do
for the period I was talking about
during the great Arab conquest of the
7th century. Okay. So that's why we have
a lot of detailed accounts including
from eyewitnesses and when you read them
yeah it was a complete utter nightmare
what was going on um what they did to
the people in Constantinople after they
had conquered it. the lucky ones. You
you said the lucky ones were the ones to
get killed. Um to speak, just so the
people know specifically, you talked a
bit about the grand duke's daughter and
and his son as well, I believe.
>> Yeah. They took her and they basically
put her on the altar of Haga Sophia and
gang raped her intentionally with a
large crucifix underneath her head. A
way of mocking of course. And yes, the
Turks were renowned for being pedophiles
of little boys. Um, especially the
conqueror of Constantinople, Muhammad II
or Mahmed. Um, he was a renowned
bisexual essentially. Um and yeah, that
that is I think one of the most um and
and in and its decisive nature is it
also heralded basically the you know the
the fact that the Turks were here to
stay in Europe now because now
Constantinople which is still of course
part of Turkey even though it's
literally on Europe if you look at the
map it's kind of weird. Turkey is its
own peninsula and then this little part
of Europe is part of it which is
Constantinople.
And once they got that foothold, then
you know the rest was just history. And
they kept continued basically moving on
further into Europe, conquering all the
Balkans, getting all the way as far
eventually as um Vienna in 1683.
>> Yeah. And as you talk about the siege of
Vienna, it really is an incredible
battle, the siege of Vienna. Uh and an
incredible story, something out of a
movie um the way the way you describe
it. But I I did want to make a quick
note that the Protestant you talked
about the Protestant Reformation during
that same time and what an impact this
really had a delletterious impact on the
movement of Christendom because it seems
that after the reformation a lot of the
Protestants would kind of take the side
or would attempt to demonize the
Catholic Church in order to up their
stock. Is that correct?
>> Yeah, it is. uh you know one can say
whatever they want about the Protestant
Reformation from a theological context.
You can be for it or against it. That's
not my affair. But from a historical
point of view, it definitely contributed
to essentially the civilizational
sundering of Christendom visav Islam.
And yes, often times due to the acrimony
between Protestants and Catholics, what
happened is in order to further demonize
Catholics, they Protestants would
naturally side with Muslims. Okay?
Because if the enemy of what we are now
seeing is the greatest evil enemy, the
Catholic Church, and if Muslims had been
fighting them for centuries, maybe
Muslims aren't all that bad.
So, and you had a lot of alliances uh
you know, Queen Elizabeth of England
would ally with Barbary, the Barbrey
pirates and you know, various uh Martin
Luther when the Turks were invading and
um he actually preached against holy war
condemning it saying you know that's a
Catholic thing and you know what God was
using the Turks to punish us because of
our evil Catholic ways until they got
close enough to him when until he
literally changed sides and said no it's
time for a we have to have a crusade or
a holy war. I don't know if he called it
a holy war, but he he definitely called
on Christians to fight back. And he it's
it's interesting. I read I read his
tract because he has to he has to
apologize for what he said earlier. He
acknowledges, yeah, I know I said that
before, but it's different because of
this that or the other reason. Okay. So,
yeah, to be sure, there's a reason that
Islam has become so rehabilitated in
more in historically Protestant nations.
And there's a reason why Islam is a
bigger problem in historically
Protestant nations because for centuries
they've essentially u stopped seeing
them as civilizational enemies. They're
just enemies of Catholics who were
enemies of as well. This is why where
where's Islam a problem today? It's in
the UK. It's in Scandinavia. It's in
Germany. Okay. Um those are the major
problem spots, the historically uh
Protestant ones because they've really
lost sight of it because of this breakup
and um this rift between the Christian
world.
>> Well, I I encourage people in this
chapter to read it. The battle is
fantastic. You have the largest uh
cavalry charge which he which you talk
about in the chapter. Also, you
mentioned in this chapter, just a quick
note, the Malta, the siege of Malta,
where where we have 130,000 cannonballs
fired. And I thought about that. That's
an awful lot of cannonballs. And then
and then you have the uh battle of
Leanto. I'm just briefly going over
which is is a popular battle uh nowadays
among people. They talk about, but boy,
that was quite a route in terms of
galley loss. Uh I think it was 12 to
230. So there's the I encourage the
readers look into this chapter, the
siege of Vienna chapter. It's it's it's
it's a fascinating chapter. But um
>> by the way, the the battle of the siege
of Malta, which you mentioned 1565, I do
only briefly mention it in two or three
pages, but you'll be happy to know since
you have it. Two Swords of Christ, I
have something like 40 pages dedicated.
>> Oh, good.
>> And you know, Mel Gibson Mel Gibson is
doing a uh
>> Everyone keeps telling me that. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Mel Gibson is doing that. I
I had the I had the good fortune of
visiting him a few weeks ago in Rome and
he's just finishing up the Passion of
Christ, but that that uh siege of Malta
I think will be great. I look I look
forward to reading it in the two swords.
Um I I
>> the book Yeah.
>> Yeah. I I that's not a bad idea. That's
not a bad idea. You know, the a lot of
Americans I brought this up after
reading your book. I told them, "Do you
know about the Barbarie Wars?" And and
it's amazing. They might have heard the
term, but a lot of people don't realize
that America's first military conflict
was against Islam. And it's not that
long ago. And I you you referenced this
in the beginning, but most people do not
realize that in the early 1800s, the
United States was fighting Islam. And
the reason we have a navy that was
established was because of the Barbarie
Wars.
>> Right? And and that's the problem which
you know because historians never add
the religious element. So we say barbar
to designate a geographical or even
national identity for North Africa. Same
thing with when when historians talk
about this this long jihadist conquest.
They don't say Islamic peoples. They say
Arabs, Sarissens, Berbers, Mo, Turks,
Tatars, Seljixs, Ottomans. Okay? And so
when you hear it that way, the the
Islamic jihadist ideological component
is missing, but it's always there and
including for the the the current one
we're talking about, the Barbrey Wars.
So when Jefferson uh so the Barbary Wars
were these Islamic slavers in North
Africa who subsisted purely on enslaving
Europeans and Christians and in just one
century they had at least 1.25 million
uh Christian slaves in the 16th century.
Um and once America uh became free in
its own nation, Britain was paying these
Barbrey uh pirates Jiza so so they don't
attack its vessels. Once they got wind
that America was no longer part of
Britain, meaning America's not paying,
it became free game. So they started
attacking American vessels, enslaving
American sailors, treating them
horrifically. It's in the book. And then
finally Jefferson and Adams, they go and
meet with one of Barbar's ambassadors
and they just they don't know anything
about Islam for all their enlightened
and enlightenment and erudition. They
don't know what's really going on with
these Islamic peoples and they say,
"Hey, can't we just um you know live in
peace, trade, be friends and uh the the
ambassador literally quotes Quran 95,
which I told you he paraphrases it." So
when I read Jefferson's letter and
Jefferson says the ambassador told us,
he says that the ambassador told him
that it's in our book that our prophet
says we have to hate you, fight you,
enslave you, ambush you wherever we find
you. That's a paraphrase of Quran 95,
the sword verse, right? And that's what
he says to Jefferson.
And long story short, you know, they the
US actually raises money, starts buying
off Barbary. Um but then eventually they
want more and more money. Um and uh in
fact to the anniversary of when the
Pasha of Tripoli, okay, May May 14th
declared war on the US starting the
Barbary Wars because he wanted more
money and Jefferson finally said no. And
the US had been secretly building up a
NA it's the Navy.
>> Is that
1801? Was that
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um, you know, I I thought it was
interesting in in your chapter how you
explained how I guess befuddled would be
the word I would use, how befuddled
Jefferson and Adams, who had had just
been, you know, working on the
Declaration of Independence, talking
about the inaliable rights of all man,
how befuddled they must have been at
this ideology. And I think Americans
should realize that
>> they're still befuddled.
>> Yes, they're still befuddled about what
going on. You also noted that in 1806
the first Quran was printed in the
United States. And um I think a lot of
well I think a lot of people will know
that but the the preface to it of this
Quran said this is not for um this is
not for cultural enrichment but really
more of a warning about a false prophet
and and absurdities.
>> Yeah. Exactly. That's that's what the
original printing of the Quran. That's
the original reason any European or
Christian translated and talked about
the Quran um was actually to get to the
bottom of why these people are the way
they are and why they keep attacking us
and talking about this jihad thing. And
that that was actually the original
reason all the Christians um would would
uh translate and talk about the Quran.
But now that's been twisted around. So,
for example, the EU has this I don't
know how many million euro project. Um,
it's called it's called the Quran in
Europe, something like that. And and
it's dedicated showing you how the Quran
and Islam were integral to European
society and civilization from the start.
Not as an antagonist, but as just, you
know, just just like the Bible was.
Okay? And they use sites like this. Oh,
look how early this Spaniard um, you
know, uh, translated the Quran. And they
they do the same thing. When I used to
work at the Library of Congress, I
worked in the Jefferson building where
where it housed Jefferson's books. And
he had a Quran. So he too bought a Quran
after this encounter to figure out
what's going on. And that Quran we would
habitually uh they would pull it out and
show it to everyone as an example of how
open-minded Thomas Jefferson was because
he wanted to learn about Islam and be
edified by it.
>> I see. I see. you know um you know in
closing uh you talk about there's a
quote from Hillair Bellac uh I think
from 1938
which you know I think people when I
read this precient quote it it was it
was very troubling reading that quote um
and basically he talks about how this is
1938 how because the west had gained so
much power people have forgotten about
this this 1400 your foe. Um, and Bellac
seems to be saying it will return. Is
that correct? Um,
>> yeah. It's interesting because he's
writing at a time when Islam wasn't a
threat. And he said, you know, this
thing is our the most ancient threat of
the Christian West and could at any time
flare out again. And lo and behold, it's
been, you know, almost a century. And
that's exactly what we're seeing. The
only difference is um and this is its
own topic but basically it's flaring out
because the west itself is allowing this
provoking this being stupid being
passive being like a doormat and
allowing Islam to do what it's doing as
an aggressive ideology not because Islam
can. The history we talked about Islam
did what it could because it could. And
Christians and Westerners tried to stop
it as best they could but they were
weaker. Now the Islamic world is weaker
than ever and the west is more powerful
than ever and yet for some reason Islam
is terrorizing it.
>> Yeah, I think you mentioned that's the
great irony of the modern times is after
all of this fight when you know either
Islam was stronger or it was a pretty
even fight in a lot of these battles.
Now where it's not even close you have
Islam invading the west which is irony.
I think you said a still swinging
scimitar will never overcome a strong
but sheathed sword which I thought was a
great quote. So I think that's something
people you know people really need to
keep in mind today. I encourage
everybody to get this book if you want
to get re some real history. uh you you
know I think people are so inner from
from going to the bookstore and reading
book biased book after biased book that
when you read this book and you get a
lot you did a great job Raymond of the
sources the endnotes I I like the
endnotes as much as as as much of
anything it's fantastic I think people
eyes will really be opened I've I've
recommended this to a couple friends I
have a famous comedian friend of mine I
I recommended it and I said I'm
interviewing you he told me well look at
the book thoroughly and and lift a few
more weights, he told me because, you
know, he said you you got to make sure
you can, you know, be be up to Raymond's
biceps, he said, which are impressive,
but but this is a guy I'll tell you
about later. But um I just want to thank
you uh Raymond for writing this book.
It's a great book. I'll put the the uh
book in the description and give a link
to it. It's out there. I have other
friends who read it. They love it. And
maybe Raymond next time um we can uh
talk about your heroes of the west. I I
got that and I started that and that's a
fantastic book. I think people need some
people to look up to some Christian
heroes because they think there's no
such thing. So maybe next time we meet
we can talk about heroes of the West and
and discuss that.
>> Sure, Justin. I appreciate it and that
sounds good. Yeah.
>> Okay. Thanks so much, Raymond. We'll
talk to you soon.
>> Sure. Thank you. Take care.
fight.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire.
name.